so check this out you guys are both
athletes so I read this great article
and it was talking about how athletes
are able to deal with pain unlike
regular people like non athletes cannot
deal with paying the way athletes so
it's real because I was just I was
suspecting that was true are you saying
that the research bears it out and so
because I know that you're an athlete
yeah well I'm just gonna continue the
next to me you are an athlete correct
alright so there's a little thing called
the pressure test
yeah you know what the pressure test is
right so you stick your hand in a bucket
of ice yeah and most people can only do
that for I don't know maybe 30 seconds
before the pain that is associated with
the with the cold causing you to pull
your hand out cuz you can't find the
last Budweiser at the bottom beer
drinkers okay I wanted to see if your
resistance to pain was any higher than a
regular person is resisting the pain and
that would be me oh so come here oh
you're gonna do the ice challenge yes I
have it right here
oh hey oh you have to we have to oh one
for each of us
fantastic okay I could tell you already
I don't want to do this
oh no no let me get an arm out so the
idea is you stick your hand in the ice
and the first person who pulls it out is
the person who has the least resistance
to pain I got a feeling that will be me
because I stubbed my toe and I call out
of work so we just do this yes right are
you ready
let me good mind I'll get mine over here
here all right okay but I got to
continue the show okay we could get
yourself ready ready okay we two one
okay go so so here's something
interesting
athletes they sit in baths they sit in
ice bath to like you know pitchers you
were a pitcher in baseball did you
didn't you ice down your shoulder yes
okay oh my god what is what is going on
here oh is it mental toughness
no no just to be clear oh not that this
doesn't hurt me it's just that I'm okay
with it
oh you are a dominatrix best dream
[Applause]
[Music]